now I want to see if you can help me
understand what kind of image would we
have in our mind for this guy this guy
down here okay now to help you
understand the picture in my head it's
just one of many I want you to think of
it kind of like this well you didn't get
it one over and over and over again
you're just going on off on off on off
okay well what's i doing if you do this
right so what's I have a pair of zero
human being human it's a number it's
just a single number we know anything to
the nose area should be one right that's
fine there's all the rules that nothing
regular numbers to do okay well what if
I just do one of them well that's a bit
boring because it's just now it starts
to get a little more interesting if I
swear I based on what I have to find I
to be I squared is the eighth one right
because I he's after all the square root
in eighth one you square it negative
lommers minutes okay
right keep going i cute hmm so my cute
is I squared times I it sucks a negative
1 times a negative
hi does that make sense okay now he's
work gets interesting if I and you'll
see why I'm drawn over here in a second
why fire I to the four squared a biggie
one test great a negative one squared a
very intense period maybe one well this
is this is I squared times I squared
right but I know what that is that's
negative one swear that's one right and
then if I keep on doing this well I sort
of come back to the beginning haven't I
right so this is going to be I as well
and then this is going to be negative
one as well and then this is going to be
negative pi as well does that make sense
so what does this a switch does not do
this switch only has two spots that it
can go what's this doing now to help you
rank
I want you to remember that in addition
to having this idea we diagrammatically
represent you know maybe numbers
integers while in another life do you
want to throw this on a number line
right so we say okay one negative one
he's the positive direction now I notice
that this I going through I over and
over again and it's negative one they're
actually related to each other right if
you do is you get two negative one and
then if you it another couple of times
you come back to one right so this it
goes on and off this you've gotta press
it four times before you get back to
your original spot right so therefore
it's kind of like from here if you press
the button twice you get to here and
then if you press it another two times
you'll come back to where you start what
would it look like to do something four
times what kind of thing could you do to
a number four times that would get you
in all different spots through the first
three times but then on the fourth time
you're back where you started and the
picture I've got is kind of like a
circle it's kind of like a quarter turn
right it's like a curse not in this
direction and now I'll do one of them
accountant facing this way and I'm doing
my second one my third one and my fourth
one brings you back to you okay so
therefore this is kind of like like if
you think of a negative numbers kind of
like a switch I think of these I
business I think of it kind of like a
propeller with like all for this just
for this guy's got four spots right that
it rotates through okay
so therefore enjoy this right I need
more than just this number one I need to
be able to get off this number line
that's what a propeller would do
conservatives okay so from this number
line
bless me I'm going to introduce a plane
okay now please no please please no this
is not a Cartesian planning right a
Cartesian plane mixes real numbers here
with other real numbers right and
so-called co-winners pair real numbers
are they work together okay but this guy
up here or down there these are not real
numbers right
this guy here would be I like you did it
once quarter turn and set you up here
you do your second quarter turn sends
you down here it's negative one if you
do another quarter turn here you'll be
at negative high and your fourth one
leads you back where you start so then
do extending a number plane into a sorry
number wine into another plane right
it's something that was um yours plenty
about guy names on the bed again people
is a I think you Swiss so just like we
named this thing when it's like you know
fixing wise you call the Cartesian plane
this thing is often called the lag and
play because it's got complex numbers on
it record okay so you've got this number
like what you used to already these are
all the numbers like all of these guys
right negative numbers irrational
numbers PI hey all these numbers you've
been working with for ages they're all
on that line just this line every single
real number is there okay but if you
want some of these widows right they
don't fit remember that was the whole
point like their imaginary wait can you
measure them they're not on the line
it's somewhere else so we call this the
imaginary axis you've got to get off
this number line in order to deal with
these numbers now if you stay with this
remember I said to you you can view
these kinds of things as a unity but
they they don't mix that it makes so
what I'll do is I can say I'm gonna
borrow the same language the Cartesian
plane has a flag X's being horizontal
and Y is being vertical if I have a real
number
like say X and some other imaginary
component which is like I lots of Y
okay then I can map out a position like
this that points remember I said to you
and here's a picture it represents a
number so you can send a whole bunch of
different ways okay
this picture also represents a number
this guy up here I'm gonna call him said
right Zhen is the customary label that
we give to complex on this and it's got
a real bit X and an imaginary bit I so X
plus iy this is the first way just like
these of representing a complex number
this form has a name they don't know
it's this chord starts with R would you
literally don't try to freak you out of
the names because just saying X plus iy
in that form is is fine it's unambiguous
we call this rectangular form because it
literally trace it on a rectangle right
it's like we just tell me where I am
let's draw a rectangle that shows me
that right just tell me the width of the
rectangle and the height of the
rectangle and now I know where you are
okay and of course that heighten that we
could go negative or negative or
negative whatever combinations you are
but you'll get a rectangle all right
that's the first way retain your form
but it's not the only way and it's not
the most special